ça voulait pas dit comment êtes vous
arrivé là derrière ce bureau d'auteur à
pied par tata ratan tata temps de dingue
dingue dingue ça fait 1 2 1 2 3 4 et
finalement vous avez réussi très vite et
très genre très très jeune mais j'ai 33
ans beaucoup de temps devant moi j'avais
beaucoup derrière aussi quant à la
réussite vous savez très bien que c'est
c'est un mot comique enfin ça ne veut ça
ne veut absolument
il ya eu d'ailleurs quand on canton
quand les auteurs pensent à la réussite
ou surtout quand ils ont l'outrecuidance
de penser qu'ils ont réussi ferait bien
tous de regarder un dessin que vous a
mis de côté que je vais vous montrer
immédiatement qui pour moi est une sorte
de bible ce petit livre petit bleu
dessinateur et un dessin de chaval voyez
si par hasard le vent de la vanité se
met à souffler à mes oreilles je
regarderai ça en réapprenant parker la
légende voiliers et je me réclame tout à
fait de ce genre de réflexion là qu'est
ce que c'est que c'est le film de
françois truffaut qui s'appelle une
belle fille comme moi et les une belle
fille comme moi c'est l'histoire d'une
d'une dame qui est l'histoire qu'il
raconte et là dessus nous avons résumé
toute l'histoire l'ail puis ou c'est
comme dans les narrations quand on est
petit je me mets des antisèches comme ça
il ne pas oublier peut-être est-elle
déjà de les centres quand elle tue son
père
[Musique]
pittman chine au japon
que signifient ces chiffres c'est un
truc de hauteur c'est un truc de c'est
un truc d'écoliers parce que en général
quand un compositeur m'envoie une
musique sur une bande magnétique
michel polnareff par exemple il chante
dans un langage indéchiffrable qu'était
son langage à lui qui précède les
paroles avec un peu d'anglais un peu de
français chantent en jouant du piano et
non pour repérer la musique ou plus
exactement pour repérer les syllabes on
peut même pas parler exactement de pied
parce que pratiquement ça serait assez
faux jeux mais des jeux mais des
chiffres pour il ya la musique a les
chiffres ensuite il ya les mollahs
d'ailleurs ce n'est pas une visite de
michelle mais cette fois les chiffres
ben je sais pas on n'en voit pas ta ta
ta ta ta ta ta ta ta ta ta ta ta ta da
da da da da da da da ça fait 1 2 1 2 3 4
5 6 7 1 2 3 4 5 6
c'est au sujet du courtier qu'est-ce
qu'il a passée ria j'ai du mal nous
recevoir
moi j'ai abordé le théâtre par le music
hall par le truchement de sketches
essentiellement de sketches pour guy
bedos et bien le gui et était d'un
acteur dont dont je me chante la musique
et la syntaxe constamment il y à
certains un certain certains mots
certaines phrases qui n'existe que par
lui parce que je sais qu'il a besoin de
prendre une certaine respiration en
disant sans et du jeu
sans être vieux jeu il ya quelques
années je faisais beaucoup de télévision
et et j'adorais j'adore toujours des
acteurs comme hubert deschamps comme
comme michel galabru
je me rappelle que vient la brûle par
exemple c'était c'était formidable de
lui mettre des adverbes alors c'est pour
moi un des meilleurs 10h02 d'adverbes
entre autres choses que je connaisse
le michel vous dire a fait un chemin non
c'est pas un peu conventionnel 1 et que
tu es venu mains de la critique qui
n'est pas sensible à la critique qui
oserait venir me dire un bout portant
qu'il n'est pas insensible à la critique
vous avez remarqué ce que c'est que
l'auteur qui a fait une très mauvaise
critique d'abord il est le premier
publiciste de cette mauvaise critique
j'ai remarqué c'est formidable
celui qui a après un filou après une
pièce de théâtre une mauvaise critique
de monsieur untel il le répète partout
dans tous les dîners dans tous les
intervenants
je pense parce qu'il est ce qu'on a
écrit sur moi et là dessus vous récite
mots d'amour l'amour la mauvaise
critique ce qui fait que ceux qui ne
l'auraient pas lui sont parfaitement au
courant et il ajoute toujours sait pas
que c'est pas qu'il n'est pas aimé ça
tout le monde a droit de ne pas aimer ce
que je fais ce qu'on fait mais c'est que
ces bêtes
c'est bête et en le même personnage si
vous le rencontrez six mois après il a
fait autre chose et il a une bonne
politique
il me dit toujours ce pas parce qu'il
dit du bien de moi et de ma pièce il
disait c'est remarquable qu'est
l'écriture est ce que c'est
quel plaisir de passer une soirée où on
s'est passé non c'est vrai c'est que il
a compris qui passe c'est une déchirure
les joueurs sur le port ou la guerre